yeah weekend in Vegas will set me back
this is a review for a movie that came
out last weekend we're going to review
it now let's review this kidnap pretty
on the nose title that is real
so kidnaps a movie starring Halle Berry
where her kid gets kidnapped as you know
from the title it probably should she'd
have to park with her kids and her kid
just disappeared she sees people
shuffling the kid into a car so she just
goes on a car chase along car chases
basically as most of the movie is her
following this car and I just like that
one thing this movie does is the parent
sees the kid being taken and then the
parent follows the car most kidnap
movies are like my kids gone I don't
know where they went to just disappear
this was like no ma'am we're going to
get into a 90s car chase and that's what
I can say about the movie it's a mom
following a kidnappers car with her kid
in that car and the moments Halle Berry
look I have nothing against Halle Berry
Halle Berry was climbing the ladder at
some point and she made that gothic a
movie I don't know the exact moment
where she started to fall like fall from
grace but it was around Gothika probably
closer to Catwoman many times yeah that
one and the movie is simplistic in
nature just like I said but I was
listening to the soundtrack I was like
this feels like you should be in the
nineties the soundtrack was a musical
score in the beginning sounded like the
score from liar liar' or something like
this is clearly a movie set in the 90s
it's not because they have cell phones
by cell phones I mean smart phones so
it's not the nineties it just has a 90s
vibe to it and the movie has exactly a
lot of what you think it would have some
decision-making a lot of close ups on
Halle Berry space a lot of her screaming
during the close ups of her face and
then things that gonna make any sense
like it looks like the movie is keeping
the identity of these kidnappers a
mystery for a reason I don't know who
they are why not why are they always
hiding their faces why do you only see
the arm hanging out the window telling
her to piss off then it shows who they
are inflected they're nobody I'm not
spoiling the movie for you that's like
me telling you the girl in the diner is
not a Marvel hero she's a girl in a
diner spoiler does the movie could have
built it to be something and it's not
something among the car chasing there's
a moment where I was she's just on these
people and they're telling her the
finger out the way they're like oh wait
go away so she was like oh they're gonna
kill my kid if I don't so she leaves and
she stops for a moment she's like all
right she circles back around that she's
following the car again they don't seem
to give a by telling her to exit
the freeway were they staying like exit
by exit I mean just don't be so
aggressive when you're following us I
mean you can follow us but just don't
follow us and the movie does have cheesy
lines that you would fly
once again showing that the movie should
either taking place in the 90s or just
been made in the nineties we know she's
like you took the wrong kid it was
missing from that Arnold's voice you
know you took the wrong kid there are a
couple of editing choices to this
intense thing happens on the freeway and
it does is weird fade I did it to
illustrate the confusion of the
situation in the moment sure yes you
feel like you're gonna pass out like mmm
maybe some of the film making shots
where someone gets thrown out of a car
this car is going really fast you hear
the engine the guys throw them out of
the car the car that is now going four
miles an hour because if you throw
someone out of a car that's moving as
fast as the car in the movie was
supposed to be moving they probably died
you don't want to hurt the actors in the
filmmaking process so you guys slow the
car down every movie that does this does
it however this one was just really
noticeable know your strengths know your
weaknesses get help where you need it
there's in the end kidnapping you yeah
so those owners that watch this could
plot light i watch this why am i
reviewing there are bitter kidnapping
movies out there that was they I'm
probably not going to remember
kidnapping t-minus one day yep
already forgot it was a forgettable
weekend of forgettable movies all right
guys so kidnap have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite kidnap fish movie the favorite
movie involving a kidnap whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more
[Music]